bulgaria's industrial heartland
a mix of soviet era architecture and air
polluting factories
pernic has the dirtiest heir in the
european union and anti-corruption
activists say the vote here stinks too
it's one among a number of towns where
business leaders are accused of paying
off voters to protect a deeply
entrenched system of official corruption
and patronage
money is always missing and really
visible for the people to see that the
money are going somewhere but not
in the citizens what we would like to
see better future for the young ones we
want to see that the government is
taking care of
our parents
public protests against corruption last
year brought an end to former prime
minister boyko borisov's decade in power
this is the man who's promised to make a
difference kirill petkov one of two
harvard educated economists whose party
continue the change looks set according
to preliminary results to lead an
anti-corruption alliance are you the
fresh face of bulgarian politics the big
hope of brussels the leaders in brussels
who want to see the page turned on
corruption here
i think i'm the fresh face for the
bulgarian voters
because our whole
election campaign started with zero
corruption not less corruption not a
decrease corruption zero corruption
if we are able today to be after today
to be in position of power
we would love to
create such a strong agency that
corruption becomes the opposite brand
for bulgaria
those are lofty aims
removing the stench of corruption will
be an enormous task a system of
oligarchy patronage and power built up
over many years helping to ensure that
bulgaria has remained the eu's poorest
member
vested interests like this won't like it
of course but the third election this
year offers at least the hope if parties
can finally work together of change
jonah al jazeera sophia